This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. All of us have had moments when we censor ourselves. A friend says something, we disagree, but instead of arguing, we smile and hide our discomfort. We go along to get along. There are times though, when we carry this deception a step further. We don't just smile and go along, we actively pretend we believe the opposite of what we really think. Why would we do that? Maybe we're attending a wedding and our hosts have prepared a
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。我们所有人都曾有过自我审查的时刻。当朋友说了一句话，我们并不认同，但我们没有去争辩，而是微微一笑，掩饰内心的不适。我们随波逐流以求相安无事。不过，有时我们会将这种伪装更进一步。我们不仅是笑着随大流，而是积极地假装相信那些与我们真实想法截然相反的事情。我们为什么要这么做？也许我们正在参加一场婚礼，而主人为我们准备了
special meal. We don't like it, but we say it's great. We feel it would be hurtful to say what we really think. Or maybe there's a new initiative underway at our company. We hate it, but we recognize that management won't look kindly at the centers. So we pretend to like the plan. At a larger scale, perhaps our country is doing something we'd detest. But protesting can get us in trouble with powerful people. So we pretend to be supporters. There are also times when we are the ones causing others to hide their true beliefs. We are the hosts of the wedding, or we are the ones who are enthusiastic about a new initiative
一份特殊的餐点。我们不喜欢，但我们说这很好吃。我们觉得说出真实的感受会伤害他人。或者，也许公司正在推行一项新计划。我们讨厌它，但我们意识到管理层不会对反对者手软。所以我们假装喜欢这个计划。从更大范围来看，也许我们的国家正在做一些我们深恶痛绝的事情。但抗议会给我们带来掌权者的麻烦。所以我们假装成支持者。有时，我们也是导致其他人隐藏真实信仰的人。我们是婚礼的主办方，或者是对公司新计划
at our company or a new policy in the country. Others pretend to agree with us because they are afraid of what we might think of them, afraid of what we might do. This week on Hidden Brain, how our personal, professional, and political lives are shaped by the fear of what other people think. I would bet that 95% of the people on this side of the aisle support intellectually this amendment. And a lot of them would vote for it if it came to vote. But no, no, no, gosh, we might poke the bear. If the present gets upset with us, then we might not be in the majority.
或国家新政策充满热情的人。其他人假装同意我们，因为他们害怕我们对他们的看法，害怕我们的反应。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨我们的个人、职业和政治生活是如何被害怕他人看法的恐惧所塑造的。我敢打赌，政坛这一边的95%的人在理性上都支持这项修正案。如果付诸表决，他们中会有很多人投赞成票。但是不，不，不，天哪，我们可能会惹恼这头熊。如果总统对我们不高兴，那么我们可能就不会处于多数派了。
And so let's don't do anything that might upset the present. Many economists study how people's choices reflect their inner preferences. If I like one product rather than another, I buy the product I like. My behavior reflects my preferences. Over the past several decades, Duke University economist and political scientist Timor Quran has studied how our outward behavior sometimes does not reflect our inner preferences. The rupture between our inner thoughts and outward actions has profound consequences in our personal and professional lives and in our politics. Timor Kharan, welcome to Hidden Brain.
所以，让我们不要做任何可能惹恼总统的事。许多经济学家研究人们的选择如何反映他们的内心偏好。如果我喜欢某种产品而不是另一种，我就会买我喜欢的产品。我的行为反映了我的偏好。在过去的几十年里，杜克大学经济学家兼政治学家蒂穆尔·库兰一直在研究我们的外在行为有时如何不能反映我们的内心偏好。内心想法与外在行动之间的断裂，对我们的个人和职业生活以及政治产生了深远的影响。蒂穆尔·库兰，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。
Thank you for inviting me. I'm wondering if we can start with a very simple example of this phenomenon that you've studied for so many years to more. We all go over to friends and neighbors' homes for a dinner party or for a birthday party. What happens in the course of these conversations that reveal this idea you're talking about where our inner thoughts don't always manifest in our outward actions and behavior? Well, sometimes when we go over to friends, we have to jointly decide what we're going to do together. And sometimes it so happens that the group perceives that everyone wants to watch a movie
谢谢您的邀请。蒂穆尔，我想知道我们是否可以从你研究了多年的这种现象的一个非常简单的例子开始。我们都会去朋友和邻居家里参加晚宴或生日派对。在这些谈话过程中发生了什么，能够揭示你所说的这种想法——即我们的内心想法并不总是表现在我们的外在行动和行为中？嗯，有时当我们去朋友家时，我们必须共同决定我们要一起做什么。有时恰好集体中的每个人都觉得大家都想看电影
when actually no one does or few do. So people to appear cooperative say that they would like to watch a movie and everybody ends up leaving the event dissatisfied or less satisfied than they could have been. They've watched a movie when none of them really wanted to spend the evening that way. And I feel I have been to dinner parties where I have not necessarily had the greatest time of my life, but when you leave, you don't tell your host, I really had a boring evening, you say nice things, in some ways your outward behavior does not necessarily reflect how you feel on the inside.
而实际上根本没有人想看，或者只有极少数人想看。因此，为了显得具有合作精神，人们说他们想看电影，而每个人最终离开活动时都感到不满意，或者比本可以达到的满意度要低。他们看了一场电影，而他们当中其实没有人真正想把这个晚上花在那上面。我觉得我参加过一些晚宴，在那里的时光不一定是我一生中最美好的，但当你离开时，你不会告诉主人，我度过了一个非常无聊的夜晚，你会说一些客套话，在某些方面，你的外在行为并不一定反映你内心的真实感受。
And in the process, you miscommunicate what you generally enjoy. So you may be giving your host and other guests, perhaps who are leaving at the same time, that you're the type of person who loves to watch movies. And maybe the same episode will occur again at the next gathering at somebody else's home. Everyone's expectation will be that this is a group that loves to watch movies, so the inefficiency will perpetuate itself. Simply because all the guests, just like you have said to the host
在这个过程中，你错误地传达了你真正喜欢的东西。因此，你可能会给主人和其他客人（也许是同时离开的其他人）一种印象，即你是那种热爱看电影的人。也许同样的插曲会在别人的下一次聚会上再次上演。每个人的期望都会是，这是一个热爱看电影的群体，因此这种低效率将会自我延续。仅仅因为所有的客人，就像你对主人说的那样
that they had a good time, so the problem doesn't correct itself. Some years ago, I think you were at USC, I believe, and you have a story about how the same behavior manifests itself in our professional life. If I recall correctly, the economics department was looking to diversify the staff and bring on more women onto the faculty.
他们度过了一段美好的时光，所以这个问题无法自行纠正。几年前，我想你当时在南加州大学，我没记错的话，你讲过一个关于同样的行事方式如何在我们的职业生活中表现出来的故事。如果我没记错的话，经济系当时正寻求使员工多元化，并将更多女性引入教职。
Tell me what happened in private conversations and in public conversations around that issue. The department was under pressure to hire more women. There was a great willingness on the part of most members of the department to do this, but there was a sense that if we limited ourselves to looking at women or had decided in advance to hire a female candidate, that we might be making a mistake, and that we would be sacrificing quality, this was not voiced, however, these concerns were not voiced in the department meeting,
请告诉我，在围绕这个问题的私下交谈和公开交谈中发生了什么。该系面临着聘用更多女性的压力。系里的多数成员都有着极大的意愿去这样做，但有一种感觉是，如果我们把自己限制在寻找女性上，或者事先决定聘用女性候选人，我们可能会犯错，我们将会牺牲质量，然而这种担忧并没有在系里的会议上说出来，
they were voiced in private conversations and when we actually started deciding and in the presence of everyone else, nobody voiced the objections that were quite commonly being voiced privately. I want to look at one third example before we tie all of these together. You grew up in Turkey and your family was a decidedly secular family and you believed in the secular project of Turkey. But there was something happening in the country at the time that you were growing up and you were a child that you didn't quite realize. You didn't realize that there were people who actually had deep disagreements with the way you and your family looked at the world and looked at the future of Turkey, but they
它们是在私下交谈中表达出来的，而当我们真正开始做出决定且当着所有人的面时，没有人说出私下里被普遍讨论的反对意见。在我们将所有这些联系起来之前，我想看第三个例子。你在土耳其长大，你的家庭是一个坚定的世俗家庭，你信仰土耳其的世俗主义事业。但在你长大和身为儿童的那个时期，国内发生了一些你并没有完全意识到事情。你没有意识到，有些人其实对你和你家人看待世界以及土耳其未来的方式有着深深的分歧，但他们
were not voicing those disagreements, but those disagreements were actually just under the surface. Can you describe to me what happened? It's those disagreements you were referring to're actually quite widespread, but they were not being voiced among secular intellectuals and secular leaders at the time when I was growing up in Turkey in the 1960s and the 1970s, a form of assertive secularism, which was not simply the separation of church and state, or in this case, mosque and state, but the control of religion by the state and the repression of religion.
并没有表达这些分歧，但这些分歧其实就在水面之下。你能描述一下发生了什么吗？这就是你所指的那些实际上非常普遍的分歧，但在20世纪60年代和70年代我在土耳其长大时，世俗知识分子和世俗领袖并没有将它们表达出来，当时那是一种强硬的世俗主义，它不仅仅是政教分离（或者在这种情况下，是清真寺与国家的分离），而是国家对宗教的控制以及对宗教的镇压。
You could not be hired by a state agency if you were a woman and wearing a headscarf. This was generating enormous resentments, and there were people who could see that these resentments were building up and that they would explode and that they could backfire, yet they could not voice these because opposing this measure would be perceived
如果你是一名女性且戴着头巾，你就无法被国家机构雇佣。这引发了巨大的怨恨，有些人能看到这些怨恨正在积聚，它们将会爆发并产生反效果，然而他们却无法表达这些，因为反对这一举措会被视为
as being against Turkey's modernization process being anti-western. So we looked at these three different domains, the interpersonal domain, the professional domain, the political domain, and even some ways connected these different things together into a common phenomenon that you call preference falsification. What is preference falsification tomorrow? Preference falsification is the act of misrepresenting one's wants because of perceived social pressures.
是在反对土耳其的现代化进程，是在反西方。所以我们考察了这三个不同的领域：人际交往领域、职业领域、政治领域，甚至在某种程度上将这些不同的东西联系成了一个你称之为偏好伪装的共同现象。蒂穆尔，什么是偏好伪装？偏好伪装是由于感受到的社会压力而歪曲自己真实意愿的行为。
And it aims specifically to manipulate the perceptions of others about one's motivations or dispositions. Preference falsification is the form of lying, but one aimed at disguising your true preference and also the information that underlies that preference. Now some people might say it sounds like self-sensorship, but you argue it's not quite the same as self-sensorship. It's broader, because preference falsification can take the form of actively pretending that you have a preference that is quite different from the preference you privately have. You may express your private preference to your spouse, to a close friend, and in public project a very different preference.
它的明确目的是操纵他人对自己动机或性格的看法。偏好伪装是一种谎言，但其目的是掩饰你的真实偏好以及该偏好背后的信息。现在有些人可能会说这听起来像是自我审查，但你认为它与自我审查不完全一样。它更广泛，因为偏好伪装可以采取积极假装自己拥有某种偏好（这种偏好与你私下拥有的偏好截然不同）的形式。你可能会向配偶、密友表达你的私下偏好，但在公开场合展现出截然不同的偏好。
That's preference falsification. It's not simply going quiet. It's not simply deciding not to enter the conversation. It can involve entering the conversation on the opposite side of where you would like to belong. To more as studied societies with widespread preference falsification, now the phenomenon can be hard to spot because people don't go around waving a flag saying that they are falsifying their preferences.
这就是偏好伪装。它不仅仅是保持沉默。它不仅仅是决定不参与对话。它可能涉及站在你本想加入的对立面参与对话。蒂穆尔研究过存在广泛偏好伪装的社会，现在这种现象很难被发现，因为人们不会到处挥舞着旗帜说他们在伪装自己的偏好。
The point after all is to misrepresent how you really feel. But one way to spot it is when one regime comes to an end and a new one suddenly springs up in its place. That's what happened in East Germany in 1989, when the Berlin Wall came down. Thousands of East Germans came across the border today, perhaps more than a hundred thousand. So many that border police lost count. So, Timor, you've done some work looking
毕竟，重点是歪曲你的真实感受。但发现它的一种方法是，当一个政权走向终结，一个新的政权突然在其废墟上涌现时。1989年的东德就是这种情况，当时柏林墙倒塌了。数千名东德人今天穿过了边境，也许超过十万。人数之多以至于边境警察都数不过来。所以，蒂穆尔，你做了一些研究，考察了
at the Soviet Union and the satellite states of the Soviet Union before and after, and somewhere is the demise of the Berlin Wall. In East Germany, what did we see before the wall came down? What did we see after the wall came down? Before the wall came down, very few people would actually admit to having been sincere supporters of the regime that fell. It became hazardous to admit that one sincerely believed in the regime. You tell the interesting story of a New York Times correspondent who went to Eastern Europe. I believe the story may have to do with Czechoslovakia, not East Germany. Tell me that story and what the correspondent found before and after in some ways the demise of communism.
苏联解体前后以及柏林墙消亡前后的苏联及其卫星国。在东德，我们在墙倒塌前看到了什么？我们在墙倒塌后看到了什么？在墙倒塌之前，极少有人会真正承认自己是那个倒台政权的真诚支持者。承认自己真诚地信仰该政权变得很危险。你讲了一个有趣的纽约时报记者的故事，他去了东欧。我相信这个故事可能与捷克斯洛伐克有关，而不是东德。请告诉我那个故事，以及这位记者在某种程度上发现的共产主义消亡前后的情况。
After several East European satellites of the Soviet Union fell in quick succession, the New York Times was full of stories about people who could finally speak the truth after years of falsifying their preferences and falsifying their knowledge. They finally felt free to criticize the regime, and every day the paper was full of stories about people who finally felt liberated. Well, it occurred to the New York Times after several weeks that they hadn't really covered the former establishment, the Communists. So they sent one of their reporters to Czechoslovakia to see how Communists were fairing and what they thought about the changes that were taking place. And in his first article,
在苏联的几个东欧卫星国相继倒台后，纽约时报上充满了关于人们在经历了多年伪装偏好和伪装知识后终于能够说出真相的故事。他们终于感到可以自由地批评政权，每天报纸上都充斥着关于那些终于感到获得解放的人的故事。嗯，几周后，纽约时报意识到他们并没有真正报道前当权者——共产党人。于是他们派了一名记者去捷克斯洛伐克，看看共产党人过得怎么样，以及他们对正在发生的变革有何看法。在他的第一篇文章中，
he sent from Prague, said, well, I went looking for Communists and I couldn't find a Communist anywhere. And people who had made a career by rising in the Communist Party, running communist organizations, they were now all saying that they were not really communists at any point, that they were simply playing along in order to advance, in order to feed their children, in order to have a roof over their head. And you see the same thing, of course, in other countries, which are not necessarily divided on, you know, on the lines of communism versus capitalism, you know, after Saddam Hussein fell in Iraq, it was hard to find people who were fans of Saddam Hussein. When a few weeks
他从布拉格发回报道称，嗯，我去找共产党人，却到处都找不到共产党人。那些通过在共产党内晋升、运营共产党组织而获得事业成功的人，现在都说他们从未在任何时候真正成为共产党人，他们只是为了晋升、为了养活孩子、为了有个遮风挡雨的地方而顺从着演戏。当然，你在其他国家也能看到同样的情况，这些国家不一定按共产主义对资本主义的路线划分，你知道，萨达姆·侯赛因在伊拉克倒台后，很难找到萨达姆·侯赛因的粉丝。而就在几周前
earlier, it was very hard to find critics of Saddam Hussein in Iraq and probably the same thing in China before and after the revolution. You see the same patterns in other countries too. Oh absolutely and in China the people who had supported the cultural revolution wholeheartedly denied that they did that after the regime fell. In Iraq people serving Saddam were doing so for the same reason that many checks and many East Germans and many Poles served their communist regimes without believing in the regime. from the preference walls fires. When we come back, how leaders create preference falsification among their followers and how dictators can get millions to fall in line.
不久前，在伊拉克很难找到萨达姆·侯赛因的批评者，革命前后的中国可能也是如此。你在其他国家也能看到同样的模式。哦，绝对是的，在中国，那些全心全意支持文化大革命的人在政权倒台后否认他们曾这样做过。在伊拉克，为萨达姆服务的人这样做，其原因与许多捷克人、东德人和波兰人服务于其共产主义政权而不相信该政权的原因是一样的。来自偏好伪装者。当我们回来时，我们将探讨领导者如何在追随者中制造偏好伪装，以及独裁者如何能让数百万人顺从。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. To more Quran is the author of Private Truths Public Lies, the social consequences of preference falsification. He points out there were many political dissidents in East Germany before the Berlin Wall came down, most preferred to remain in the shadows. After the Wall came down and the Communist regime crumbled, there were many East Germans who still felt loyalty toward the old regime, but now, with the tide turned, it was the turn of these Communist sympathizers to remain silent, to hide their true beliefs. Tomorrow I want to talk about how authoritarian regimes create the conditions for preference
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。蒂穆尔·库兰是《私人真相，公开谎言：偏好伪装的社会后果》一书的作者。他指出，在柏林墙倒塌之前，东德有许多政治异见人士，大多数人选择保持沉默。在柏林墙倒塌、共产主义政权崩溃后，许多东德人对旧政权仍有忠诚感，但现在，随着大局已定，轮到这些共产主义同情者保持沉默、隐藏真实信仰了。蒂穆尔，我想谈谈威权政权是如何为偏好
falsification and I want to jump forward from the 20th century to the 21st century. In 2013, the world woke up one day to news from North Korea. This morning, North Korea. Can you talk a moment both about what happened in North Korea if you remember that incident tomorrow, but also about the larger idea about the strategic use of violence in order to enforce preference falsification? I do remember that episode one of its effects was to make North Korea's dictator signal that absolutely anyone could be punished and punished severely for this loyalty. If Kim can execute a relative and do so without
伪装创造条件的，我想从20世纪跳跃到21世纪。2013年，世界有一天醒来，听到了来自朝鲜的消息。今天早晨，朝鲜。你能花点时间谈谈朝鲜发生了什么（如果你还记得那个事件的话），以及关于利用暴力策略来强制推行偏好伪装这一更大概念吗？我确实记得那个插曲，它的影响之一是向朝鲜独裁者发出信号，表明绝对任何人都可以因为不忠而被严惩，而且是严惩不贷。如果金可以处决一名亲属，并且可以不经
any due process, we could do this to anyone. Authoritarian regimes like that of North Korea, the limit descent or eliminate descent entirely, also by blocking the emergence of a civic society. Individuals are not allowed to form groups that have any autonomy. The state controls everything. A second measure that these regimes used is to give people the sense that they are always being watched. There are cameras everywhere, there are informants everywhere, and people are encouraged
任何正义程序就这么做，我们就可以对任何人这样做。像朝鲜这样的威权政权，通过阻止公民社会的出现来限制异见或完全消灭异见。不允许个人组建任何自治的团体。国家控制一切。这些政权使用的第二项措施是让人觉得他们时刻被监视。到处都是摄像头，到处都是告密者，人们被鼓励
to send information to the regime about signs of the scent to give the sense that no one is immune. No matter how small your community, no matter how useful you are to the regime, no matter how close you are to the dictator himself, you are not immune. If you are disloyal or you signal that you might be disloyal, that you're sympathetic to the centers, you will be punished. You will be punished. You know, I am remembering a video from that incident that was probably circulated by state media. And if I recall correctly, it showed Kim's uncle. You know, this was a major party gathering with hundreds and hundreds of senior people in North Korea gathered. And Kim's uncle was basically grabbed from this big meeting in full public view of all these other people,
向政权发送有关异见迹象的信息，以制造一种没有人能幸免的感觉。无论你的社区有多小，无论你对政权有多大用处，无论你与独裁者本人有多亲近，你都无法幸免。如果你不忠，或者你发出可能不忠的信号，即你同情异见者，你就会受到惩罚。你将受到惩罚。你知道，我正记起当时那段很可能是由国家媒体传播的视频。如果我没记错的话，它显示了金的叔叔。你知道，这是一场有数百名朝鲜高级官员聚集的大型党代会。而金的叔叔基本上是在众目睽睽之下从这个大型会议上被抓走的，
taken outside the meeting and was shortly thereafter given a trial, quote unquote a trial, and then shot. You could argue if Kim wanted to get rid of his uncle, he could have put his uncle on trial or had his uncle arrested at his home and then, you know, had a trial and secret and done all of this in hiding. But in some ways, the very visibility of what happened that you could not just take North Korea's number two man and have him executed, but you could take him from this meeting of all the dignitaries of North Korea, really sent a signal in some ways that no one
被带出会议室，不久之后就被进行了一场所谓的审判，也就是引号里的审判，然后被枪决。你可以争辩说，如果金想除掉他的叔叔，他可以审判他的叔叔，或者在家里逮捕他的叔叔，然后，你知道，秘密审判并把这一切隐藏起来。但在某些方面，所发生的事情的极高可见度——你不仅可以带走朝鲜的二号人物并将他处决，而且可以从朝鲜所有显贵的这次会议上带走他——确实在某种程度上发出了一个信号，即没有人
was safe. I wanted to talk for a moment about the theatricality of the violence that is often necessary to enforce this kind of preference falsification. The choreography here includes not just the audacity of dragging Kim's uncle out of this gathering, but the fact that nobody in the audience objected. Everybody, and these were powerful people, were part of the North Korean regime. There were military leaders, there were industrial leaders,
是安全的。我想花一点时间谈谈这种暴力所具有的戏剧性，这种暴力通常是强制执行这种偏好伪装所必需的。这里的编排不仅包括把金的叔叔从这个聚会中拖出来的胆大妄为，还包括观众中没有人反对这一事实。每个人（这些都是掌权者）都是朝鲜政权的一部分。有军事领袖，有工业领袖，
there were major political leaders. Nobody lifted a finger to defend the uncle. This is part of the theatrics. To demonstrate to the entire nation that if you are the sloyal, if you do anything that threatens the regime, nobody will come to your help because everybody is living in fear. This is part of the system of control. Saddam did something very similar,
有主要的政治领袖。没有人动一根手指去保护这位叔叔。这是戏剧性的一部分。向整个国家证明，如果你不忠，如果你做了任何威胁政权的事情，没有人会来帮你的忙，因为每个人都生活在恐惧之中。这是控制系统的一部分。萨达姆做过非常相似的事情，
except it was even more dramatic. In one of the party congresses, he identified somebody in the audience, had them dragged out and shot in the hallway, and the entire party congress heard the shot and nobody made a move. And that was Saddam's way of communicating the same message. And of course, this was very widely publicized for the same reason that Kim White, the same message, and of course this was very widely publicized for the same reason that Kim widely publicized his execution. So we imagine that in totalitarian states, the powers that be hold on to power through ruthless acts of violence, like we've just been talking
只是戏剧性更强。在一次党代会上，他认出了观众中的某个人，让人把他拖出去在走廊里枪决，整个党代会都听到了枪声，却没有一个人采取行动。那是萨达姆传达相同信息的方式。当然，这得到了非常广泛的宣传，原因与金广传达相同信息的原因相同，当然，这得到了非常广泛的宣传，原因与金广泛宣传他的处决相同。所以我们想象，在极权国家，当权者通过残酷的暴力行为维系权力，就像我们刚才所讨论的那样
about. And of course, this is true, but you say this does not explain how widely preference falsification is practiced. And in some ways, if you looked at the prison population, for example, of the of the old Soviet Union, you don't necessarily see a huge number of people in prison. In other words, you don't need many, many examples of this kind of violence to actually have preference falsification multiply itself across an entire society. No, you don't. Of course, there were periods in the Soviet Union of massive violence under Stalin. There were millions of people who were either executed or sent to the Gulag Archipelago in Siberia. This does happen, but when we look at the Eastern
。当然，这是真的，但你说这并不能解释偏好伪装被广泛实践的程度。在某些方面，如果你看看例如旧苏联的监狱人口，你未必会看到监狱里有大量的人。换句话说，你不需要很多很多这种暴力的例子来让偏好伪装在整个社会中自我倍增。不，你不需要。当然，在斯大林统治下的苏联，曾有过大规模暴力的时期。有数百万要么被处决，要么被送往西伯利亚古拉格群岛的人。这确实发生了，但当我们审视整个东欧
Europe as a whole and if we look at Soviet history, we see periods when there was actually very little violence. The violence committed earlier was enough to keep people in line, you just needed to punish people occasionally. And there was the case of a high-level person in the East German Secret Service who was found guilty of something and he was demoted to being the doorman. And this was a visible reminder to everyone every day as they entered the big building of the German Secret Service of what could happen, how you could lose all your comforts and all your privileges. of Eastern Europe, like Chakrasovakia, where there was actually very little violence that prisons did not have an especially large number of political prisoners, what kept the system going is that people were expected to turn on dissidents and to avoid befriending them, even if they agreed with them. So when Vatslav Havel, the famous writer and later the president of Czechoslovakia and then later president of the Czech Republic, when he and a few friends of his signed the declaration called Charter-77, which asked the Czech Republic
的历史，并回顾苏联历史时，我们会发现有些时期的暴力实际上非常少。早先犯下的暴力足以让人们保持循规蹈矩，你只需要偶尔惩罚一下人。曾有一名东德秘密警察的高级官员因某事被判有罪，他被降职为门卫。这对于每天进入德国秘密警察大楼的每个人来说都是一个可见的提醒，提醒他们可能会发生什么，你如何会失去所有的舒适和特权。东欧的其他地方，如捷克斯洛伐克，那里的暴力实际上非常少，监狱里并没有特别多的政治犯，维持这个系统运转的是，人们被期望去背叛异见人士并避免与他们交朋友，即使他们同意他们的观点。所以当瓦茨拉夫·哈韦尔（著名的作家，后来的捷克斯洛伐克总统，再后来的捷克共和国总统）当他和他的几个朋友签署了被称为“七七宪章”的宣言时，该宣言要求捷克共和国
essentially to respect certain human rights. The government launched a campaign of vilification and expected citizens to participate in it. Millions of people, including school children, wrote letters to newspapers, condemning these traitors, these monsters, and the people who signed the declaration lost many of their friends. There were people who, when they saw them walking down the street, they moved to the other side. So, it was not to have to say hello to them. So, what sustained
基本上尊重某些人权。政府发起了抹黑运动，并期望公民参与其中。数以百万计的人，包括小学生，给报纸写信，谴责这些叛徒、这些怪物，而签署宣言的人失去了许多朋友。有些人当看到他们在街上走时，会走到路的另一边。所以，为了不必向他们打招呼。因此，维持
these East European regimes was not just the punishments that were delivered by the regime. It was not just the oppression of the regime, but it was actually people helping to vilify the enemies of the regime or the a result of the fear they feel from the top, in some ways they're becoming enforcers themselves and in some ways that's how the system perpetuates. The system perpetuates itself by turning the victims into victimizers and everyone becomes complicit in this system of oppression which also creates a great deal of guilt in people. One of the reasons why Vatslav Havils' friends would move to the other side of the road when they saw him coming is that it gave them pain to have to ignore what's love, not say hello to him, or as the case might be, to have to say something insulting to him when they actually deep down they admired what he was doing,
这些东欧政权的不仅是政权施加的惩罚。不仅是政权的压迫，实际上还有人们帮助抹黑政权的敌人，或者是他们感受到来自高层的恐惧的结果，在某种程度上他们自己也变成了执行者，在某种程度上这就是系统得以延续的方式。该系统通过将受害者变成迫害工具来维持自身，每个人都成为这个压迫系统中的同谋，这也给人们带来了极大的负罪感。瓦茨拉夫·哈韦尔的朋友在看到他走过来时会走到马路另一边的原因之一是，不得不忽视瓦茨拉夫、不向他打招呼，或者视情况不得不对他说一些侮辱性的话，这让他们感到痛苦，而实际上他们内心深处很钦佩他在做的事情，
and they felt ashamed that they were not part of this group of dissidents themselves. this group of dissidents themselves. So each act of conformism, each act of preference falsification that is undertaken to buy some comfort becomes a burden on everyone else. It makes everyone else feel the need to issue similar signals. So one of the profound implications of this theory is that it helps explain something that seems mysterious otherwise, which is when you look at different societies, the speed at which revolutionary change can sometimes unfold
并为自己不是这群异见人士中的一员而感到羞耻。他们自己就是这群异见人士。因此，每一次顺从的行为，为了换取安逸而采取的每一次偏好伪装的行为，都成了压在其他人身上的负担。它让其他人感到有必要发出类似的信号。因此，这一理论的深远含义之一是，它有助于解释一些原本显得神秘的事情，即当你观察不同的社会时，革命变革有时展开的速度
is often staggering. So even we talked about East Germany earlier, more than three quarters of East Germans had not foreseen that the fall of communism was coming. Most people believe the regime was stable. Can you talk about this idea of how preference falsification in some ways conceals vulnerabilities in societies and allows in some ways for revolutionary change to happen? This was true in your own native land of Turkey. It's true in the Islamic Revolution in Iran in 1979.
通常是惊人的。因此，正如我们之前讨论过的东德，超过四分之三的东德人没有预见到共产主义的垮台即将到来。大多数人认为政权是稳定的。你能谈谈这种观点吗：偏好伪装在某种程度上如何掩盖了社会的脆弱性，并在某种程度上允许革命变革的发生？这在你自己的祖国土耳其是真实的。1979年伊朗伊斯兰革命也是如此。
It's true in China. Many other places, the speed of change, can be explained in some ways by the extent of preference falsification. Yes, in these repressive regimes, there are millions of people who are doing what is expected of them to signal that they are supporters of the regime when they actually are dissatisfied, but they don't reveal themselves. While they are becoming increasingly dissolutioned,
在中国是这样，在其他许多地方，变革的速度在某种程度上可以用偏好伪装的程度来解释。是的，在这些压制性政权中，有数百万人做着对他们来说顺理成章的事，以表明他们是政权的拥护者，而实际上他们心怀不满，却不表露出来。随着他们日益幻灭，
they are still going along, they are still informing on others. But if a few people get to the point where they do say enough is enough, you get to the point where you're ready to jump in. But we don't know until movement gets going, we don't see that actually the potential is there. So even the CIA did not see the East European revolutions coming. The KGB did not see this. The dissidents themselves did not see it. As the signs of the approaching revolution started to multiply, what stuff Havill was asked
他们仍在随波逐流，仍在向他人告密。但如果少数人达到了受够了的程度，你就会达到准备好加入其中的地步。但在运动兴起之前，我们并不知道，我们看不到其实这种潜力是存在的。因此，连中情局也没有预见到东欧革命的到来。克格勃也没有预见到这一点。异见人士自己也没有预见到。随着临近革命的迹象开始倍增，瓦茨拉夫·哈韦尔被问及
whether a revolution was coming. And he said, let's stop dreaming. He didn't see it coming. And this is true in some ways of your own family's experience in Turkey tomorrow. I mean, your family in some ways, as we discussed earlier, were decidedly secular. They believed in the idea of a secular Turkey. They believed that this would be the regime going forward.
革命是否即将来临。他说，别做梦了。他没有预见到它的到来。在某种程度上，这适用于你自己的家庭在土耳其的经历，蒂穆尔。我的意思是，正如我们之前讨论的那样，你的家庭在某种程度上绝对是世俗的。他们信仰世俗土耳其的理念。他们相信这将是未来的政权。
Your family failed to see what was coming down the pike. This is correct. And when I was growing up in Turkey, I failed to see what was coming in. I failed to see the resentments that were building up. I bought into the notion that there were some obscurantists or very conservative Muslims who were backward thinking but with modernization their numbers would diminish and education would solve the problem there was nothing to worry about. I did not see at the time the pain that this was generating and the many resentments that it was generating that would cause huge problems for Turkey down the road. Your scholar of Islamic studies, besides the other work you've done, and one of the interesting things you've looked at recently,
你的家庭未能看到即将来临的风暴。这是正确的。当我在土耳其长大时，我未能看到即将发生的事情。我未能看到正在积聚的怨恨。我接受了这样一种观念，即有一些思想落后的 obscurantist 或非常保守的穆斯林，但随着现代化，他们的人数会减少，教育会解决这个问题，没有什么好担心的。当时我没有看到这正在造成的痛苦，也没有看到它正在产生的许多怨恨，这些怨恨将在未来给土耳其造成巨大的问题。你是一位伊斯兰研究学者，除了你做过其他工作之外，你最近关注的趣事之一，
is the rise in some ways of atheism in many parts of the Muslim world. Can you talk a little bit about that? Because again, that's the flip side of what you've just described, happened in Turkey. What is the data show in terms of what's happening underneath the surface in many Muslim majority countries? majority countries. The percentage of atheists and deists, people who classify themselves as believing in God but not in Islam is rising and the figures are startlingly high even at religious schools, they are in double digits. In Iran, religiosity has fallen dramatically. The evidence from Saudi Arabia shows rise in the percentage of
是穆斯林世界许多地方无神论的兴起。你能谈谈这一点吗？因为这同样是你刚才描述的发生在土耳其的事情的反面。数据显示了穆斯林多数国家表面之下的情况如何？多数国家。无神论者和自然神论者的比例（即将自己归类为信仰上帝但并非信仰伊斯兰教的人）正在上升，即使在宗教学校，这些数字也高得惊人，达到了两位数。在伊朗，宗教信仰急剧下降。来自沙特阿拉伯的证据显示，比例有所上升
atheists and people who have secretly converted out of Islam. None of this, of course, gets captured in public statistics, and you won't see it in outward behaviors. But actually, what happened in Turkey is now happening in reverse. In the middle of the 20th century, it was genuinely religious people who were hiding their religiosity and pretending to be secular. Now there are many people who are actually secular, who are pretending to be religious, or who no longer believe in God, or who no longer believe in God or who no longer believe in Islam but are pretending publicly to do so. Fear has changed sides and the form of religious preference falsification has changed sides. It's just the same phenomenon but the opposite side is benefiting. We've looked at preference falsification in North Korea, the Soviet Union, and other repressive
无神论者以及秘密改宗离开伊斯兰教的人。当然，所有这些都没有被公开统计数据捕捉到，你在外在行为中也看不出来。但实际上，土耳其发生的事情现在正在逆转。在20世纪中叶，真正虔诚的人隐藏他们的宗教信仰并假装是世俗的。现在有许多人实际上是世俗的，却假装虔诚，或者不再信仰上帝，或者不再信仰上帝或不再信仰伊斯兰教，但在公开场合假装如此。恐惧改变了阵营，宗教偏好伪装的形式也改变了阵营。这只是相同的现象，但对立的一方正在受益。我们考察了朝鲜、苏联和其他压制性
regimes. It's clear that totalitarian states create ideal conditions for the formation of preference falsification. Many of us might imagine that countries with a free press, with protections for free speech, democracies, these would not be nations where preference falsification flourishes. But is that true? When we come back, we'll take a closer look at preference falsification in the United
政权中的偏好伪装。很明显，极权国家为偏好伪装的形成创造了理想条件。我们中的许多人可能会想象，拥有自由新闻、保护言论自由的国家、民主国家，这些不会是偏好伪装盛行的国家。但这是真的吗？当我们回来时，我们将仔细审视美国的偏好伪装
States. When Timur Koran first began proposing his ideas about preference falsification some two decades ago, many of his colleagues said, okay, that kind of stuff happens in repressive totalitarian regimes. It can't happen in democracies like the United States, where the freedom of expression is enshrined in the Constitution. Timur says, this was a dangerous misunderstanding. You don't need re-education camps in Siberia to frighten people into falling in line.
在美国。当蒂穆尔·库兰大约二十年前首次提出关于偏好伪装的观点时，他的许多同事说，好吧，那种事情发生在压制性的极权政权中。它不可能发生在像美国这样的民主国家，因为言论自由已被写入宪法。蒂穆尔说，这是一个危险的误解。你不需要西伯利亚的再教育营来恐吓人们顺从。
Recent studies show a majority of Americans are afraid to share their political views, whether they are Democrats or Republicans. Of course, it varies depending on the context, depending on whether the country is red or blue, but a substantial share of Americans are afraid that if they express their political views truthfully, that they will get demoted, they might get fired, and there are substantial numbers of Americans who believe that people who hold the wrong political views should be fired, should not be given opportunities. And this is just a very concrete cost of today of expressing political views. I want to look at preference falsification
最近的研究表明，大多数美国人害怕分享他们的政治观点，无论是民主党人还是共和党人。当然，这因背景而异，取决于国家是红色还是蓝色，但相当大一部分美国人担心，如果他们真实地表达自己的政治观点，他们会遭到降职，他们可能会被解职，而且有相当数量的美国人认为，持有错误政治观点的人应该被解职，不应该获得机会。这只是今天表达政治观点的非常具体的成本。我想看看偏好伪装
on both the right and the left and maybe start with a Republican party. I want to go back to 2016 and candidate Donald Trump in the 2016 presidential election. He was a very unusual candidate. He said many things that were unconventional for a politician. He played on some of the questions we've been talking about because he articulated views that many people may have held, but were uncomfortable expressing themselves. And so he became their vehicle for the views. But also in interpersonal conversations and debates,
在右翼和左翼都有体现，也许从共和党开始。我想回到2016年以及2016年总统大选中的候选人唐纳德·特朗普。他是一个非常不同寻常的候选人。他说了很多对政治家来说很不寻常的话。他利用了我们一直在讨论的一些问题，因为他表达了许多人可能持有但又不好意思自己表达的观点。因此，他成了他们观点的载体。但在人际对话和辩论中，
Trump regularly insulted many of his opponents. Sometimes he went so far as to insult not just his opponents, but the families of his opponents. I remember one time he mocked the appearance of Heidiy crews the wife of senator ted crews from texas brump has clearly attacked cruises wife by putting up that side by side of the two women with cruises wife looking very awkward not a great moment for her and mullonia trump looking you know like a model
特朗普经常侮辱他的许多对手。有时他甚至不仅侮辱对手，还侮辱对手的家属。我还记得有一次他嘲笑德克萨斯州参议员特德·克鲁兹的妻子海蒂·克鲁兹的外表，布鲁普显然通过并排展示这两位女性的照片来攻击克鲁兹的妻子，克鲁兹的妻子看起来很不自然，这对她来说不是个好时刻，而梅拉尼娅·特朗普看起来（你知道的）像个模特
uh... so i mean basically he was, my wife's prettier than yours is. Can you talk a bit about the ways in which these dramatic expressions of insult may have in some way shaped how Republicans started to respond to Donald Trump? You started to recognize that if you crossed him in a debate, you were not just gonna get a policy response, you were gonna get a smackdown,
呃……所以我的意思是基本上他是在说，我老婆比你漂亮。你能谈谈这些戏剧性的侮辱表达在某种程度上是如何开始塑造共和党人对唐纳德·特朗普的反应的吗？你开始认识到，如果你在辩论中惹恼了他，你不仅会得到政策回应，你还会遭到痛打，
you were gonna get insulted, maybe even your family members would get insulted. Yes, this is something it's analogous to the theatrics in North Korea and in Baghdad. We talked about through those insults and attacks Trump was sending in 2016 that if you crossed them no matter who you were you would get attacked and he would try to destroy your reputation and that his followers would join in attacking you. And it was very important that he demonstrate that nobody was immune to this. He has attacked leading commentators on Fox News who have been among his supporters. He's tried to destroy the reputations. He's insulted them. The message he sends by doing that is very similar to the message North Korea's dictator sent when he had his
你会受到侮辱，甚至你的家属也会受到侮辱。是的，这类似于我们在朝鲜和巴格达看到的戏剧性场面。我们讨论过，通过这些侮辱和攻击，特朗普在2016年发出信号：如果你激怒了他，无论你是谁，你都会遭到攻击，他会试图摧毁你的声誉，他的追随者也会加入攻击你的行列。非常重要的是，他要证明没有人能免于这种命运。他攻击了福克斯新闻上曾是他支持者的主要评论员。他试图摧毁他们的声誉。他侮辱了他们。他通过这样做传递的信息，与朝鲜独裁者公开处决其叔叔时传递的信息非常相似
uncle executed in plain sight Everyone went along with what happened nobody objected in Trump's case very few people defend went along with what happened, nobody objected. In Trump's case, very few people defend publicly the person who was being attacked, the person who was picked by Trump to be part of his cabinet. And suddenly he's demonized, he's fired, and very few people stand up for him.
每个人都顺从了发生的事情，没有人反对。在特朗普的案子里，极少有人公开捍卫被攻击的人，那个被特朗普选中成为其内阁成员的人。而突然间他被妖魔化了，他被解雇了，极少有人为他挺身而出。
People continue to support Trump. So there's a parallel here in the tactics being employed to build and maintain power. I want to play you a clip of Republican Senator Bob Corcor, chastising his fellow Republicans for being unwilling to cross President Trump, even if that meant sacrificing their core beliefs about free trade policies. I would bet that 95% of the people on this side of the aisle support intellectually this amendment. And a lot of them would vote for it if it came to vote.
人们继续支持特朗普。因此，在建立和维持权力的策略上存在着相似之处。我想放一段共和党参议员鲍勃·科克谴责他的共和党同僚不愿意违抗特朗普总统的剪辑，即使这意味着牺牲他们关于自由贸易政策的核心信念。我敢打赌，政坛这一边的95%的人在理性上都支持这项修正案。如果付诸表决，他们中会有很多人投赞成票。
But no, no, no, gosh, we might poke the bear. If the president gets upset with us, then we might not be in the majority. And so let's don't do anything that might upset the president. So look, I'm a no. Pretty remarkable tomorrow. In some ways, when I'm hearing that, I'm hearing in some ways the language of preference falsification. Absolutely.
但是不，不，不，天哪，我们可能会惹恼这头熊。如果总统对我们不高兴，那么我们可能就不会处于多数派了。所以，让我们不要做任何可能惹恼总统的事。所以听着，我投反对票。蒂穆尔，这相当引人注目。在某种程度上，当我听到这个时，我听到了某种偏好伪装的语言。绝对是的。
And people are afraid, in this case, Republican office-solders are afraid, if they cross Trump, he might not support them in their reelection bid that Trump might support an opponent more to his liking. So there have been many people who privately wish that Trump would go away and disagree with many of the policies that he is pursuing, disagree vehemently with his style, style, but don't object even his opponents in the 2016 election in the primaries like Ted Cruz and Marco Rubio have fallen in line. Yeah, I mean, and one of the things you said earlier stuck with me, which is that in some ways each time he did one of these things and people did not cross him, it sent a signal and the signal was not just that he could say whatever he wanted, the signal was that no one would actually stand up to him from his own party.
人们对此感到恐惧，在这种情况下，共和党官员害怕如果他们惹恼了特朗普，他在他们竞选连任时可能不会支持他们，甚至可能支持一个更合他心意的人。因此，许多人私下里希望特朗普消失，不同意他推行的许多政策，强烈反对他的风格，但他们甚至不敢反对。2016年初选中反对他的人，比如泰德·克鲁兹和马可·鲁比奥，也都顺从了。是的，你之前说过的一点深深触动了我，那就是在某种程度上，每当他做出这些举动而人们没有站出来反对他时，这就释放出一个信号，而这个信号不仅是他可以随心所欲地发表言论，更意味着党内竟然没有人敢真正站出来对抗他。
And of course, once you do that, you essentially send a signal that going forward, you are alone if you basically stand up and cross Donald Trump. And in some ways, that is so similar to what you were telling me earlier in the conversation we were having about Kim Jong-un or what happened in Turkey or what happened in the Soviet Union. And he actually articulated his strategy quite well when he said I could shoot somebody on Fifth Avenue in New York and nothing would happen to me. This was a signal he was sending to all Republicans, not to cross him, that he could do anything to them, and the party would stay behind him. His reason for attacking McCain was also an element of this strategy. McCain is a hero of both the right and the left. Why you might ask would Trump, while he's running for president in 2016, go out of his way to criticize McCain as a loser for having become a prisoner in Vietnam, you would think that
当然，一旦你这样做了，实际上就等于发出了这样一个信号：展望未来，如果你选择挺身而出并与唐纳德·特朗普作对，你将孤立无援。从某种意义上说，这与你早些时候在谈论金正恩、土耳其或者苏联时所提到的情况惊人地相似。他其实非常清楚地表达了自己的策略，当他说出“我如果在纽约第五大道开枪打死一个人，也不会有任何事”时，这就是他向所有共和党人发出的信号，告诫他们不要与他作对，他可以对他们做任何事，而党内依然会支持他。他攻击麦凯恩的原因也是这一策略的一部分。麦凯恩是左右翼共同敬仰的英雄。你可能会问，为什么特朗普在2016年竞选总统期间，还要刻意批评麦凯恩因在越南被俘而成为“失败者”呢？你可能会认为
tens of millions of Republicans would be horrified by that. Well his strategy there was to show that he could take on even a hero like McCain. Many observers and I would include myself in the group did not appreciate at the time. When he attacked McCain, I thought, well now he's gone a step too far. He's lost the military vote, but he actually went up in the polls, not down. We're having this conversation in late November 2020. It's been about three weeks since the general election. And it's really striking because I think everyone generally senses that most Republicans believe
数以千万计的共和党人会对此感到震惊。然而，他的策略正是要表明，他甚至连麦凯恩这样的英雄也敢挑战。许多观察人士——我也包括在内——当时并没有意识到这一点。当他攻击麦凯恩时，我想，这下他可走得太远了，他肯定会失去军方的选票。但事实上，他的民调支持率不仅没有下降，反而上升了。我们是在2020年11月下旬进行这次谈话的。距离大选结束已经大约三个星期了。这真的很引人注目，因为我认为大家普遍感觉到，大多数共和党人都认为
the election is over, that Donald Trump lost and that Joe Biden won. And yet the number of Republicans who've been willing to come forward and actually say this, you know, you can count them on the fingers of one hand the prominent republicans who've been willing to come forward and do that i mean this is really preference falsification in spades this is preference falsification in spades most republican elites believe that trump lost the election, it turns out that 88% of Republicans in general believe the election was stolen. Trump may continue whether he actively tries to run in 2024 or not. He may continue leading the party and he may play a very important role in selecting not only the next nominee of the Republican Party, but also nominees in various states.
大选已经结束，唐纳德·特朗普落败，乔·拜登获胜。然而，那些愿意站出来公开承认这一点的共和党人屈指可数，你用一只手的手指数得过来那些愿意站出来表明立场的知名共和党人。我的意思是，这简直就是彻头彻尾的偏好伪装，这绝对是极其彻底的偏好伪装。大多数共和党精英都认为特朗普输掉了大选，但结果显示，总体上有88%的共和党人认为大选被窃取了。无论他是否会在2024年积极参选，特朗普都可能会继续下去。他可能会继续领导党派，并在不仅是共和党下一任总统候选人的选择上，而且在各州候选人的遴选上发挥非常重要的作用。
So many Republican office holders are at the moment just waiting to see what will happen just waiting to see what will happen, and while they are waiting, they are continuing to play this game of also supporting his efforts to overturn the result of the election. Let's look at an example of preference falsification on the left. In 2020, over the summer, especially,
因此，许多共和党官员目前正处于观望状态，只是在等待局势的发展。而在等待的同时，他们仍在继续玩着支持他推翻大选结果的政治游戏。让我们来看看左翼偏好伪装的一个例子。在2020年夏天，尤其是，
the country was captivated by the Black Lives Matter movement. And this was especially true in California. In the 2020 election, one of the things that was on the California ballot, the ballot proposition for Californians was to vote on affirmative action. And I want to play you a little clip of what happened in that ballot initiative. California voters soundly rejected Prop 16, which would have restored affirmative action and racial preferences.
整个国家都被“黑人的命也是命”运动所吸引。在加利福尼亚州尤其如此。在2020年的选举中，加州选票上的议题之一、针对加州选民的投票提案是关于平权行动的。我想播放一小段关于该投票提案结果的录音。加州选民坚决否决了第16号提案，该提案原本将恢复平权行动和种族优待。
Every single major elected Democrat, Kamala Harris, Gavin Newsom, big labor unions across the state, big organization, nonprofit organizations, all in favor of it, but the voters said no. Can you talk about this for a moment to more, that there was such support for Black Lives Matter in 2020, and you would think that a state that basically was strongly for Black Lives Matter would also support affirmative action, but in some ways it seemed as if the private
每一位主要的民主党民选官员——卡玛拉·哈里斯、加文·纽森、全州各大工会、大型组织以及非营利组织——全都支持它，但选民们却投了反对票。你能就此多谈谈吗？2020年社会对“黑人的命也是命”有如此巨大的支持，你会认为一个基本上强烈支持该运动的州也会支持平权行动，但在某些方面，情况似乎并非如此。加州人的私下
preferences of Californians was not being revealed in the protests that we saw on the streets. This is not new, affirmative action, whether it's racial affirmative action or gender-based affirmative action. It has generally been unpopular, even in heavily democratic states. This is what we find when we pull people giving them anonymity. In public, though, especially in heavily democratic states, many people pretend that they support it. And the extensive preference falsification is especially high among educated people, among corporate leaders in academia, in journalism.
偏好并没有在我们街头看到的抗议活动中显现出来。这并不新鲜，平权行动，无论是基于种族的还是基于性别的平权行动，通常都不受欢迎，即使在深蓝的民主党州也是如此。当我们通过匿名方式对人们进行民调时，就会发现这一点。然而在公开场合，特别是在民主党占绝对优势的州，许多人假装支持它。这种广泛的偏好伪装在受过教育的人群、企业领袖、学术界以及新闻界尤为严重。
And so because they strongly support affirmative action, we get the sense that this is a widely supported policy measure, but in fact it is not. So between the 2016 and 2020 elections, Donald Trump, who is widely seen as a misogynist by those on the left, lost support among men, but held steady with women, between the 2016 presidential election and the 2020 presidential election. Trump's obviously was also seen widely by those on the left as a racist, but he lost ground among white voters and gained ground among blacks, Latinos, and Asians.
因此，由于他们强烈支持平权行动，我们便会产生这是一种广受支持的政策举措的错觉，但实际上并非如此。因此，在2016年和2020年大选之间，被左翼普遍视为厌女者的唐纳德·特朗普，在男性选民中的支持率有所下降，但在女性选民中的支持率保持稳定。从2016年总统大选到2020年总统大选，特朗普在左翼眼中显然也被视为种族主义者，然而他在白人选民中的支持率有所下降，但在黑人、拉丁裔和亚裔选民中的支持率却有所上升。
Now, many of the differences between 2016 and 2020 are small, but it's revealing that Trump did not lose ground among the very groups who were said to be affected the worst by his presidency. There are lots of theories about why this has happened. Can preference falsification explain some of these outcomes to him? Absolutely. And we need to recognize it's possible for a person to dislike Trump as a person, think that he did a horrible job,
现在，2016年和2020年之间的许多差异虽然很小，但很有启发意义的是，特朗普并没有在那些据说受其总统任期打击最严重的群体中失去支持。关于为什么会出现这种情况，有很多理论。偏好伪装能解释其中一些结果吗？完全可以。我们必须认识到，一个人完全有可能在私下里不喜欢特朗普这个人，认为他做得糟糕透顶，
think that he said horrible things, perhaps against them, their Latino, and he has said these characterized all Hispanics as rapists and murders. And at the same time, like certain positions that he is taking, controversial positions he's taking, I think this probably explains why Trump did not lose ground among African-Americans and why he even gained ground
认为他说过极其恶劣的话，也许是针对他们的，比如他是针对拉丁裔的，而他曾将所有西班牙裔统称为强奸犯和杀人犯。但与此同时，他们又喜欢他所采取的某些立场，即他所采取的那些充满争议的立场。我认为这或许可以解释为什么特朗普在非裔美国人中的支持率没有下降，以及为什么他甚至在
among Muslims. It's tourling now to know exactly why these groups supported or increased their support for Trump. But I think that we're going to find out that these certain policies that the leftists likes and that Trump has very vocally supported and pursued probably played a role. They wouldn't admit it publicly, which is why the pollsters missed the rising support within those groups, but probably these are the factors that drove the rise in Trump's support. One of the really interesting things that you say
穆斯林群体中提升了支持率。现在要确切知道这些群体为什么支持或增加了对特朗普的支持还为时尚早。但我认为我们最终会发现，左翼厌恶而特朗普却非常大声疾呼并极力推行的某些政策，很可能在其中发挥了作用。他们不会在公开场合承认这一点，这也是为什么民调机构漏掉了这些群体中上升的支持率，但这些很可能就是推动特朗普支持率上升的因素。你关于偏好伪装所阐述的极其有趣的一点是
about preference falsification is that there are ways to express your discontent with a regime or with a new system, but you have to do it in a way that is subtle, and one of the ways you can do it is through humor. I want to play you a clip of the comedian Chris Rock talking about war culture at the Academy Awards where he was hosting. It's the 88th Academy Awards, which means this whole no-black nominees thing has happened
偏好伪装的其中一个特点是，存在着表达你对政权或新系统不满的方式，但你必须以一种微妙的方式去做，而其中一种方式就是通过幽默。我想播放一段喜剧演员克里斯·洛克在奥斯卡颁奖典礼上谈论黑人电影人抗议浪潮的录音，他当时是主持人。这是第88届奥斯卡颁奖典礼，这意味着整个“没有黑人提名”的事情已经发生过
at least 71 other times. Okay, you got to figure that it happened in the 50s, in the 60s, and black people did not protest. Why? Because we have real things to protest at the time. You know, you have real things to protest. You know, it's too busy being raked and lynched to care about who won best cinematographer. What's revealing here to more is not just that he's making the joke, but that the audience is laughing, and this might not be an audience that's actually very comfortable with what he's saying.
至少71次了。好吧，你得想想看，这种事在50年代、60年代都发生过，当时黑人并没有抗议。为什么？因为我们那时有更现实的事情要去抗议。你知道的，当时有切实的事情需要去抗议。你知道的，大家当时都忙着逃命和躲避私刑，根本顾不上关心谁获得了最佳摄影奖。这里引人深思的不仅是他在讲笑话，还有台下观众的笑声，而这些观众实际上可能并不那么认同他所说的话。
Can you talk a little bit about how humor sometimes is a marker of what's underneath the surface in many societies. Humor is used in repressive societies and in context where people feel constrained in what they can say or to signal that one is aware of certain contradictions without taking ownership of the preferences being expressed or the facts being pointed to. In laughing, they signal that they understand what is being communicated, but don't have to take ownership for it. It's almost like the court gesture role in sort of ancient times. I mean, the one person who could speak truth to the king was the court gesture because it was understood that the gesture was gesting and everyone can laugh and you can discuss sort of truths that are beneath the surface without being marched off to be executed. Yes, this is exactly the role that comedians play and comedy flourishes in repressive
你能简单谈谈为什么幽默有时是许多社会中潜意识表露的标志吗？幽默被用于压抑的社会以及人们在言论受到限制的环境中，以此来表明人们意识到了某些矛盾，同时又无需对所表达的偏好或所指出的事实承担责任。通过发笑，他们示意自己理解了所传达的信息，但又不必为此承担所有权。这几乎就像是古代宫廷里的弄臣角色。我的意思是，唯一能对国王说真话的人就是弄臣，因为大家心知肚明弄臣是在搞笑，每个人都可以笑，你也可以讨论隐藏在表象之下的某些真相，而不会被拉出去处决。是的，这正是喜剧演员所扮演的角色，喜剧在压抑的
societies and it tends to gravitate toward areas where preference falsification is rampant, looking at the comedy shows is a good place to start. I'm wondering why the preference falsification is more likely to help people and groups who have strong views or extreme views rather than moderates. I mean, if you think they should be, for example, zero immigration to the United States, you can call anyone who has even mildly pro-immigrant views, you know, a traitor. On the other hand, if you think that they should be open borders to the United States,
社会中蓬勃发展，并且往往倾向于那些偏好伪装极其猖獗的领域，观察喜剧节目是一个很好的切入点。我想知道为什么偏好伪装更有可能帮助那些持有强烈观点或极端观点的人和群体，而不是温和派。我的意思是，如果你认为，例如美国应该实行零移民，你就可以把任何哪怕只有轻微亲移民观点的人称作叛徒。另一方面，如果你认为美国应该开放边际，
you can call anyone who calls for any immigration restrictions a racist. I feel it's harder to do this if you have moderate views precisely because moderation suggests a certain amount of flexibility, nuance, or even compromise. Does preference falsification, you think, tend to drive moderation out of the conversation and reward extreme positions? It does, and it's one of the manifestations of it is the hyper polarization we see in the United States today. In both parties we are seeing struggles between extremists and moderates and it's the moderates who are finding it necessary to falsify their preferences, to give up certain nuances in their arguments, and those individuals find it very risky to participate in debates because they get demonized by both sides.
你就可以把任何呼吁实行任何移民限制的人称为种族主义者。我觉得如果你持有温和观点，就很难做到这一点，恰恰是因为温和表明了一定程度的灵活性、细微差别甚至妥协。你认为偏好伪装是否往往会将温和逐出对话并奖励极端立场？确实如此，这也是今天美国看到的极度两党极端对立的表现之一。在两党内部，我们都能看到极端派与温和派之间的争斗，而正是温和派发现自己有必要伪装自己的偏好，放弃他们论点中的某些细微差别，这些个体发现参与辩论风险极高，因为他们会遭到双方的妖魔化。
I'm wondering if you can talk a moment about what the consequences of this are. What are the consequences? I mean, we've seen in some ways how preference falsification operates and sort of the effects that it has. But what are the consequences? Should we just simply say, well, you know, different groups rise and fall, different things come to the fore at different times. What are the negative effects of preference falsification?
我想请你谈谈这带来的后果是什么。后果究竟是什么？我的意思是，我们在某种程度上已经看到了偏好伪装是如何运作的以及它所产生的种种影响。但后果到底是什么？我们是否应该轻描淡写地认为，好吧，你知道的，不同的群体起起落落，不同的事物在不同的时间占据中心。偏好伪装的负面影响究竟有哪些？
What are the things that it doesn't allow us to do that are a freer expression and sharing of ideas might allow us to do? One of the huge causes that we can't have an informed debate, all sorts of ideas that might prove very useful, don't get expressed. And bad ideas don't get scrutinized because people are afraid of criticizing them. And sometimes they're on some issues, there are two extreme ideas that are surviving in different communities, one on the right, one on the left, neither gets scrutinized, neither gets criticized, people who have reservations, people who have ways of improving the ideas. They don't express themselves.
它剥夺了我们做哪些事情的能力？而这些事情本来可以通过更自由地表达和分享观点来实现。其中一个巨大的危害就是我们无法进行理性的辩论，所有那些可能证明非常有用、各种各样的观点都无法得到表达。而糟糕的观点也无法受到审视，因为人们害怕批评它们。有时在某些问题上，不同的社群中会同时存活着两种极端的观点，一个在右翼，一个在左翼，结果两者都不受审视，两者都不受批评，那些有所保留、拥有改善这些观点方法的人们，根本不敢表达自己。
Well if the potential solutions, potential remedies don't get expressed, then nobody will build on them. So we've seen how preference falsification has all these negative effects. I want to spend a moment talking about a couple of potentially positive effects of preference falsification. Can you talk a moment about how in some ways preference falsification might play a role in maintaining norms of decency and mutual respect because in some ways we are afraid to cross one another. This might go all the way back to the initial conversation we were having. If everyone expressed everything they were feeling in their hearts,
好吧，如果潜在的解决方案和潜在的补救措施得不到表达，那么就没有人能够在此基础上去构建它们。我们已经看到了偏好伪装如何带来所有这些负面影响。我想花点时间谈谈偏好伪装的一些潜在积极影响。你能谈谈在某种程度上，偏好伪装如何在维护体面和相互尊重的规范方面发挥作用吗？因为在某种程度上我们害怕彼此冒犯。这可能要追溯到我们刚开始时的对话。如果每个人都把内心的真实感受毫无保留地表达出来，
much social interaction would come to a grinding halt because if we actually told everyone what we thought of them, we would likely have very few friends left. That's true, and that you've pointed to one of the favorable consequences of preference falsification. We have friends who have bad taste in what they wear. We have friends who get terrible haircuts. If we expressed our preference, this would
那么许多社会互动将会彻底陷入停顿，因为如果我们真的把对每个人的真实看法都告诉对方，我们恐怕就没几个朋友能留下了。确实如此，你指出了偏好伪装的有利后果之一。我们都有着穿衣品味糟糕的朋友，我们都有理发剪得很糟糕的朋友。如果我们直言不讳地表达我们的偏好，这会
make it quite uncomfortable for them. And if everyone reminded us of all the things they didn't like about us all the time, it would be pretty uncomfortable for us. So preference falsification is also an instrument of civility. Isn't it also the case that if you look at our major political parties, there are really coalitions of different and often competing interests. So on the right, you have country club, free market republicans who have to get along with populists and evangelicals. On the left, you might have supporters of the MeToo movement who want to punish sexual predators, who have to sit together and work together with people
让他们感到相当不自在。而且，如果每个人都时刻提醒我们他们身上所有不喜欢我们的地方，那对我们来说也会相当难受。所以，偏好伪装也是一种维系文明的工具。难道不是吗？如果你看看我们的主要政党，它们实际上都是不同且常常是相互竞争的利益集团的联盟。因此在右翼，你拥有乡村俱乐部派、自由市场派的共和党人，他们必须与民粹主义者和福音派共和党人相处。在左翼，你可能拥有“我也是”运动的支持者，他们想要惩罚性侵犯，这些人必须与
who argue there's too much incarceration and too much punishment in the country. Can you talk a moment about how, in some ways, preference falsification allows these coalitions to stick together? And I think it's partly the same phenomenon you were describing a second earlier. It comes about because largely people are willing to hold their tongues or bite their tongues instead of saying everything that's on their minds. Yes, absolutely. I would add that they are unstable coalitions. One of the things that has held the Democratic Party together in the 2016-2020 period is a common hatred
那些认为这个国家监禁过多、惩罚过重的人坐在一起并共同工作。你能谈谈在某种程度上偏好伪装是如何让这些联盟凝聚在一起的吗？我认为这部分原因和你刚才描述的现象如出一辙。它的出现主要是因为人们愿意隐忍不发，或者说咬紧牙关，而不是把脑海中的想法全部说出来。是的，绝对如此。我要补充的是，它们是不稳定的联盟。在2016年至2020年期间，将民主党凝聚在一起的因素之一，就是对
of Trump and a common desire to get rid of him because he's undermining various projects that they hold a deer. Once Trump is gone and they are governing, they will have to make choices. And what we are going to see in the 2020 to 2024 period under Joe Biden is we're going to see whether he is able to hold this coalition together by making the various constituencies bite their tongue on various issues to keep facade of unity. In 2016, 2020, Trump was the person who did that to call the shots and kept the coalition together and various groups like the country club're about to see is whether in the absence of a ruthless president who's willing to destroy the reputation of literally anyone who crosses him to keep his coalition together, to keep his base together, whether in the absence of such a president, one who is more used to compromising and who is more civil will be able to keep the democratic coalition together. To more Quran is an economist and political scientist at Duke University.
特朗普的共同憎恨，以及想要摆脱他的共同愿望，因为他正在破坏他们珍视的各种计划。一旦特朗普离任并开始执政，他们就必须做出抉择。我们在2020年至2024年乔·拜登执政期间将要看到的是，他是否能够通过让各个选区在各种问题上咬紧牙关、以维持团结的表面现象，来将这个联盟凝聚在一起。在2016至2020年期间，特朗普就是那个发号施令并把联盟凝聚在一起的人，而诸如乡村俱乐部派等等不同的群体……我们即将看到的是，在没有一个冷酷无情、愿意不惜摧毁任何敢于与他作对的人的名誉来维系其联盟和基本盘的总统的情况下，在没有这样一位总统的情况下，一个更加习惯妥协、更加注重礼貌的人是否能够将民主党联盟凝聚在一起。蒂穆尔·库兰是杜克大学的经济学家和政治学家。
He is the author of Private Truths Public Lies, the social consequences of preference falsification. Timur, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you very much for the discussion, Shankar. It was an honor. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Medural Media is our exclusive advertising sales partner. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarell, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyd is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
他是《私人真相，公开谎言：偏好伪装的社会后果》一书的作者。蒂穆尔，非常感谢你今天来到《隐秘大脑》。非常感谢你的探讨，尚卡尔，这是我的荣幸。《隐秘大脑》由隐秘大脑传媒制作。麦杜拉传媒是我们独家广告销售合作伙伴。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·夸雷尔、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊德是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐秘大脑》的执行主编。
Our run sun hero for this episode is our former producer, Raina Cohen. Raina first introduced me to Timor Koran's work while we were working on another episode. I've been fascinated by the theory of preference falsification ever since. Rainer has also shaped many other hidden brain episodes. As a colleague, she was always thoughtful and kind. We miss her and are so grateful for all her contributions to our show. For more hidden brain, you can follow us on Facebook, Twitter and at hiddenbrain.org. If you liked this episode, if you found it timely and valuable, please take a moment and
我们这一期的幕后无名英雄是我们前制片人雷娜·科恩。雷娜在我们在制作另一期节目时，首次向我介绍了蒂穆尔·库兰的作品。从那以后，我一直对偏好伪装理论着迷不已。雷娜还塑造了许多其他《隐秘大脑》的节目。作为同事，她总是体贴而善良。我们想念她，并对她为我们节目所做的一切贡献深表感激。想要了解更多《隐秘大脑》的内容，你可以在Facebook、Twitter以及hiddenbrain.org上关注我们。如果你喜欢这一期节目，如果你觉得它及时且有价值，请花一点时间，
tell a friend or colleague about hidden brain. I know I say this all the time, but I really mean it. It would mean a lot to me if you could think of one person who might enjoy our program and tell them about it. If your friend is new to podcasting, please show them how to subscribe to our show. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you next week. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
向朋友或同事推荐《隐秘大脑》。我知道我经常这么说，但我是认真的。如果你能想到哪怕一个人可能会喜欢我们的节目并把节目推荐给他，对我来说意义重大。如果你的朋友是播客新手，请教教他们如何订阅我们的节目。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。下周见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。